joining us now though as a pair of boss
ladies identical twins
Antoinette Clarke and Trisha Clarke
Stone give it up Double Down bet on
yourself and succeed on your terms
welcome ladies why did you write this
book and I'm so excited about reading it
because I just saw a couple excerpts and
I was like yeah yeah we wrote the book
to really democratize success for people
that look like us if we think about it
women make up about 50% of the workforce
but we're highly underrepresented when
it comes to executive roles and then
last year alone only 20 for fortune 500
companies were led by female CEO that's
just absurd to us 24 what's the total
number like fortune 500 yeah oh my gosh
and out of that one was a woman of color
so we wrote this book so that we become
the norm and not that it's authentic and
do you want to talk to internet about
what she's always hogging the space
Kelly's things do you know it's taken us
a long time to get to where we are today
in our book essentially debunks a lot of
status quo myths and we're trying to
really push that forward so women
understand that they need to challenge
them so they can be boss ladies you
don't need to be an entrepreneur or CEO
to achieve boss-lady status we all can
do it absolutely so what is the mix that
you bust in the book the first is
everyone cares only about how hard you
work but the truth is people care about
how smart you work it's about
achievement verse activity so you really
want to focus on the milestones and not
the time and the way you do that is to
be strategic and really lean into clear
goals and objectives I love that I'm
gonna be so much better for reading this
book I can't wait so what's the neck of
a second myth is basically people feel
like they should care only about how
well you do things that are asked of you
but the important thing is doing things
that aren't asked of you which sounds a
little crazy don't but you have to go
beyond your JD so beyond your job
description and think of the long game
exactly like look it might not be in
your job description but this thing the
other day wasn't in mind and you just do
it because it needs to
right and that's what you want your
advice though it just isn't for working
women
no it's for okay go ahead all women
right cuz every woman doesn't want to
become a corporate executive or an
entrepreneur but what we do want is to
be celebrated and respected for who we
are moms that stay-at-home yeah I mean I
would take any other job in the world
I have children it is hard to constantly
be just responsible for molding this
human 2470 just a home and you can't you
lose your identity there's all so much
going on I think this book isn't just
for people in any kind of industry it's
for any person like any woman really
trying to find the best part of you and
be the best you absolutely the best
version of yourself the moms are the
CEOs of household right boss lady yes
yes yes I make my husband step up though
y'all luckily I married a true cowboy he
does that on his own so I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this